while everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast cannabis as amina on oh
therapy for 21st century acquired immune
deficiencies presented by dr. judy Mike
Ovitz founder and consultant at mark Inc
and director of cancer biology at EPI
gen-x
pharmaceuticals i'm susie valdez of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab routes labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I want to remind you that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during a presentation just click on
that ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on that screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the help desk
button located on the promotional board
at the bottom center of your screen or
use that ask a question and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and offers
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits please
join me now in welcoming our presenter
dr. Mike Ovitz I will now turn the
presentation over to welcome dr. Mike
Ovitz hey thanks so much it's a delight
to be here and talk about a really
exciting topic as far as therapeutic
potential for some of the most
devastating diseases of our time and and
that's using cannabinoids as stem cell
therapy and immune therapy so on that
first slide there that you see ahead of
you you see some of those diseases you
see of cancers a lot of hormone
sensitive cancers a lot of Leukemia
Lymphoma
bladder cancers these are these are
cancers that that tend to respond to
immune therapy we also consider
autoimmune diseases lupus inflammatory
bowel disease Crohn's disease
polymyositis sodium's syndrome Boucher's
disease and primary biliary cirrhosis to
live a chronic liver disease in the CNS
we think of myalgic encephalomyelitis
Gulf War Syndrome autism spectrum
disorders MS Parkinson's disease Lou
Gehrig's disease on to the deep diseases
which are increasing in in our world at
a really extraordinary rates due to the
environmental toxins in our world and
interestingly as as we've learned only
in the last two decades that are that
are really diseases of the
endocannabinoid system and and of stem
cells where those toxins are are
affecting our immune system and the
regulation of our immune system in
really profound ways so on the next
slide
on the next slide I show a relatively
recent paper review article from
progress in lipid research and what this
review article talks about is as is what
we learned in in the early 90s the
endocannabinoid system and how it's
actually critical for stem-cell
development really from the embryonic
stem cell on and so what we're gonna do
today is we're gonna talk about how the
endocannabinoid system in the regulation
of the endo endocannabinoid system is
key to a healthy brain and a healthy
immune system I know this paper is open
access so it's available to a lot of the
audience and I've adapted or taking
figures directly
this is paper and added some of our own
as shown on slide three so at the stem
cell level in the endocannabinoid system
there's really cannabinoid receptor 1
and cannabinoid receptor 2 you see here
in the lower part of the screen those
are shown as these channel like
receptors these are g-protein coupled
receptors and so they have they cross
the membrane say six or seven times and
the signal ease occur and changes can
occur in the loops and they have
crosstalk with many many Chi coupled
receptors for signaling both in the
brain and in the immune system what
we've learned recently is the Hamato
poetic stem cell which is the stem cell
that it's involved in you're in the
development of all of the lineages in
your blood shown on this slide we're
showing I'm showing you the myeloid
lineage that's on the megakaryocytes the
erythrocytes red blood cells mast cells
myeloblast
on the right hand side the figure wasn't
long enough for this slide I just show
also the basal field neutrophils
eosinophils and critically the monocyte
macrophage which we're going to talk a
lot about today the myeloid cells and
and hematopoiesis of the myeloid cells
this is really your innate immune
response your frontline defense from all
of the toxins in our environment in our
world not just not just environmental
toxins but including things like viruses
our expertise is in retroviruses and our
work at epidemics is is all about how a
retrovirus has changed the expression of
genes and not the DNA or an including at
the DNA level but primarily the
expression of genes and this is one
mechanisms how they cause diseases by
dis regulating
the Hamato poetic stem cell and what you
get is an accelerated aging where we
seek answers in those autoimmune and
neuro-immune diseases on the first slide
in younger and younger populations
driven by this amount of poetics
themselves so what what this paper shows
now is that in fact this cb2 endo
cannabinoid receptor is is involved in
the development of essentially every
lineage of the myeloid a matter poetic
stem cell and it's involved in those
diseases that I showed on on the first
slide if you notice the asterisks on the
first slide what we were looking at is
diseases associated with activated
macrophages activated microglia cells in
the brain so so now we know that there
there's a primary disposition towards
cb2 in the hematopoietic stem cell and
that dysregulation of these responses in
these myeloid progenitors is can be
causal for these diseases and that we
can reverse these diseases with with
phyto cannabinoids and modulating our
endogenous produce cannabinoids on the
next slide we see that we continue to
look at how the cb2 is associated with
chronic inflammation of the nervous
system which is somewhat paradoxical and
because in fact from a mesenchymal stem
cell shown on the left side of the slide
we see that the cb1 receptor that can
have the the canonical cannabinoid
receptor number one another g-protein
linked safety knowledge shown in blue
and cb2 is shown in red for convenience
is is actually controls the development
of
neurons so the development of neurons
the development of adipocytes fat cells
creativity sites and and bone formation
so that's somewhat paradoxical and
thinking about that because if I had on
those slides cancers that metastasized
to the bone and are primarily bone
cancers such as multiple myeloma and in
prostate cancer which are two diseases
in which bone formation is dysregulated
so you see there on the left-hand side
though the protoss t oblast is regulated
by cannabinoid receptor number one and
involved in in Frankl is the receptor of
NF kappa-b activation of NF kappa-b
ligand and NF kappa-b which we'll
discuss in a moment is really key to
inflammatory responses and inflammation
that drives in fact the breakdown of the
pro do audio Plast so what you see is
you get osteoclast favoring over
osteoblasts that you're breaking down
the bone progenitors and you're actually
getting bone resort resorption so we see
in these cancers and in these diseases
and of course osteoporosis in women of
younger and younger ages driven by you
know it's now it's it's still a theory
but driven by these interactions is the
theory that we're working on in
developing their therapeutics to
modulate the topic of this discussion so
on the right on the in the middle of the
slide you can see how red arrows
blocking the breakdown of the proto a
steel clasp and encouraging the build-up
and in development and lineage
commitment to the osteoblasts and the
bone formation is is critical is driven
by blocking the cb1 receptor blocking
and promoting on the left hand side
whereas cb2 is is driving both it's
directly activating the osteoclast
through a mechanism with the question
mark we still don't know because that
cb2 receptor hasn't necessarily been
identified on that Selin and we have
some ideas that we'll discuss in the
next few slides and that's why the
question mark for the top era at arrow
but we absolutely know when the cb1
receptor is TB - cross talk interacts
where the weight of the balance as I
show on the left hand side it's not an
on/off switch
but really a gradient so I look at the
endocannabinoids system as a dimmer
switch on the immune system really a
master regulator at many different
levels but by of the stem cell Y of the
mesenchymal stem cell via the matter
poetics themselves and how it's a
gradient so the more receptor that is
expressed as it's up regulated the more
you'll get the bat accumulation we can
also think in our society about how the
fat accumulation and metabolism is
changing in our teenagers and our young
adults you know through the
dysregulation of this system so one of
the recent discoveries big discovery
shown on the next slide is that that
question mark may be addressed in a
paper by Brian Gardner in his colleagues
and that is that tetra hydro cannabinoid
which is the psychoactive THC in medical
marijuana actually turns on CB - driving
that g-protein coupled receptor to break
down ATP this is called pure energic
signaling where where ATP is broken down
into cyclic KMP this activates the
expression of a critical master
regulator of hematocrit exten cells and
stem cells in general known as
transforming growth factor beta or
tgf-beta
dr. resetti the other half of mark Inc
it's my kibbutz and resetti consulting
here and and dr. resetti more than 25
years ago was the scientists who made
the discovery that tgf-beta acts on the
stem cell as a bi-functional regulator
of hematopoiesis that means it can go
both ways tgf-beta can be a really good
general in in regulating immune
responses
a good soldier or a bad general so if
the pathway is on tgf-beta can turn it
off in as far as the immune system and
if the pathway is off tgf-beta turns it
on so it has both autocrine back on
itself back on the stem cell to maintain
the stem cells
Delmas and peregrin to develop those
effector lineages i showed on that first
slide so critical critical regulator and
here we have THC that's you know been
really outlawed in in our world for more
than 70 years and and it's critical so
cannabinoid formulations without THC
actually cannot not regulate and cure
diseases and in these therapies can be
curative but you really can't spell
health care without THC so it's THC too
dependent and we have to think about
formulations driving the cb2
interestingly enough the psychoactive
effects of THC are are mediated through
that cb1 receptor which I showed here on
the last slide so it's those neurons and
that are are driven by THC because of
course there's crosstalk between the two
receptors so so it's a it's a question
of balance really but it's interestingly
enough if we can develop and we're
working to develop
cb2 agonists that don't interact with
cb1 that block that interaction and then
you don't have the psychotropic effect
that is such a problem with with using
these therapeutically now that we can
use them to still regulate the critical
hematocrit ik component so the next
slide I show in some respects that to go
back to our first slide and think about
what's causing the autoimmune neural
moon and acquired immune deficiencies of
our time
well our expertise is in HIV AIDS and
the reason I call these 21st century
acquired immune deficiencies because of
course there's not HIV in all of these
diseases but in every disease on the
first slide where I showed an asterisks
there is a retro viral component and we
won't go into retrovirus biology but
what we know is that in our treatment of
in the development of actually curative
therapies for HIV which doctors Eddie
and I participated in at the National
Cancer Institute in the 80s and 90s
those therapies included at some level
cannabis and so this the the people that
survived and and and thrived with HIV
were the ones that were using
cannabinoids along with the
antiretroviral therapies which we
developed in our laboratory and of
course because of the stigma and and the
the legal problems with using it that
that really wasn't known at that time
and we've only recently known that so
what we knew about cannabinoids is that
they were antiviral and they reduce
inflammation because we see that
blocking arrow on the right side so LPS
is Lippo polysaccharide and it's on
bacteria so bacteria and poly IC mimics
an RNA virus infection so RNA viruses
are your flu viruses your
maybe your retroviruses your Ebola your
Zika these are all RNA viruses so poly I
see mimics the activation of these toll
receptors and then these pathways that
that generate the type 1 interferons
which are curative for retroviruses
almost all retroviruses and RNA viruses
actually tend to block this type 1
interferon pathway and we use type 1
interferons interferon alpha interferon
beta as immune therapy in that disease I
highlighted known as primary biliary
cirrhosis which is actually associated
with a retrovirus known as human beta
retrovirus so here we have an and we
know with HIV and hepatitis C in various
liver diseases which are driven by
hepatitis B is a para retrovirus that
means it has components of retroviruses
and DNA retroviruses we use interferons
as therapy so here now we have
cannabinoids which are able to drive
block these pro inflammatory mediators
which are so important for driving the
disease process
it's the chronic inflammation and the
chronic activation of the monocyte
lineage of that myeloid lineage which we
discussed and we'll discuss a little a
lot more today that is driving the
disease process in HIV associated
dementia we knew it had nothing to do
with virus copy number so patients who
were on antiretroviral therapy and had
non detectable levels of HIV still had a
dementia and and could develop diseases
that look like our early Alzheimer's
disease that look like Parkinson's and
multiple sclerosis diseases and those
are diseases that have all been
associated with it but you don't need
expression of the virus and it's the
idea that we're driving these
inflammatory mediators and and stopping
the
interfere on responses in in that way
and this is we're right in the middle of
it the cannabinoids modulating that at
cb2 receptor are critical and actually
curative if you drive it in the other
direction so the next slide shows you a
little bit more of that neuroprotection
so we've talked about cannabinoids
either phyto or endogenous those made by
your body on being actually neuro
protective so therapeutics where you
drive the neuro protection through those
central mediators but I show here in
this slide critically there are
antioxidant cannabinoids and I show in
the on the left hand side it's going
through a factor known as erythroid
factor to the nuclear erythroid factor -
and that factor is is a key pathway it's
a transcription factor in a pathway that
is really key to sleep as you see it it
drives the production it's upstream of
the production of superoxide dismutase
which is a key liver enzyme for detoxing
at the level of delivering mutations and
alterations genetically and
epigenetically silencing s OD is
critical to the development of Lou
Gehrig's disease so these are the
familial ALS and Parkinson's disease
have a have a problem with making enough
superoxide dismutase or have
dysfunctional enzyme at that level so
these antioxidant cannabinoids actually
don't signal through C b1 or C b2 and
we're unsure about that of what the
crosstalk is and what the receptors are
but I'm no matter because their lipid
mediators and your memories shown here
as lipid bilayers they go right through
these lipids cannabinoids or lipids and
they go right through they stimulate NRF
to increase superoxide dismutase
synthesis and
decreased these damaging brain damaging
reactive oxygen and reactive nitrogen
species so we all know about the
antioxidants is so Pro oxidation and an
oxidative stress it's known as is a key
contributor to every disease on that
first slide and particularly the
neurological diseases so it is those
it's it's these pathways here that are
really important for are critically
important for neuroprotection in neuro
inflammatory diseases so we can see the
intersection right at that level for
further neuroprotection we also see
introduced on the left hand side that
the anot endogenous cannabinoids and CB
1 agonist whether they be phyto
cannabinoids other terpenes or synthetic
cb1 modulators are important for
regulating brain-derived neurotropic
factor that's really a key neurotropic
factor for developing new the
development of new neurons so we the key
discovery here in the last two decades
since the since the endogenous
cannabinoids system was discovered that
we actually make and respond to
cannabinoid molecules and they're
critical to all of our development of
both the brain and the immune system we
can actually develop new brain cells we
can actually drive through cb1 agonists
and endogenous cannabinoids neurogenesis
so that's really key to any of the
diseases I showed like ALS multiple
sclerosis the DI elating diseases this
actually shows the capacity to
remyelination new neurons and and really
be curative therapies for things even
like autism spectrum disorders on which
um in in this family of myalgic
encephalomyelitis that's inflammation of
the brain and the muscles in adults they
call it mecfs and in in children they
they end up with autism spectrum
disorders but they're in the same they
have the same types of immune disorders
that an AIDS patient would have even in
the absence of the virus indicating
other toxins going on so they're key to
neuro protection by cb1 driven
endocannabinoids and by tow cannabinoids
right in the middle you see the
intersection between the immune system
and and the the brain and the immune
system in the brain are really connected
from conception and we and we know this
now and the immune system is the brain
is not what we used to consider the
immune privilege by immune privilege we
means they could have an inflammation of
an antigen and it would not stimulate an
inflammatory response that's simply not
true because the microglia traffic
stream that means it starts in the bone
marrow and those myeloid cells that I
showed on that the first few slides and
the brain derived monocyte macrophage
means traffic by molecules known as kima
cons those molecules known as chemokines
are also regulated epigenetically that
means at the expression level so while
you can inherit changes in that toxins
in our environment like aluminum like
mercury some of the things that they're
shown to be so heavily associated with
the development of Alzheimer's diseases
those those and and autism spectrum
disorders are that that pathogenesis is
hypothesized and and and now more and
more data support to be driven by
activated microglia so you see the
microglia is at the interface because
they express both cb2
cannabinoid receptor number two and they
crosstalk they talk all day to the Aster
glia and the the astrocytes and the
aster glia are important in glioblastoma
the brain cancers we all you know know
of the upregulation and the increase of
the of the brain cancers the
glioblastoma is in our world and and the
it's it's proposed that cannabinoids and
and in fact really shown therapeutically
that they can be not only helpful but in
this slide actually curative for these
devastating brain cancers that that
killed Vice President Biden Joe Biden
son a few years ago so critic critical
and thinking about therapeutic
opportunities where the microglia by
simply deactivating so it's the
activated microglia that is pathogenic
because it releases that inflammatory NF
kappa-b in a it leases the activity
pro-inflammatory cytokines the reactive
I each oxygen and nitrogen species and
really is driving the breakdown so you
want that cannabinoid receptor to
through tgf-beta through THC to down
regulate as we saw in the last slide to
down regulate and actually allow cb1 to
drive neural protection so maybe the
metabolic substrates and the anti unbe
anti-inflammatory tgf-beta are really
critical to it and it's this crosstalk
between the microglia and the Aster glia
and the expression of both and probably
through antioxidant in other non
canonical cannabinoid receptors that
modulate all of these process so we can
see how the excitement is there for all
of us that that we've we've probably
uncovered a key therapeutic entity that
can um that can actually cure some of
the most devastating
diseases of our time the next slide
shows even further to that now there
have been rejected detected that they're
actually cb1 receptors on the
mitochondria so in on the astrocyte i we
blew up in in a paper that i've
referenced somewhere in here i'll make
sure i put the reference on paper but
this is a January 2018 paper in the
journal of neuro psychopharmacology and
this paper talks about of the the title
of it is cb1 receptors from ubiquity to
specificity so cb1 receptors in the
endocannabinoid system they're expressed
on essentially every cell in the body
and every tissue in every disease from
cardiovascular disease to lung disease
could be a part of those neurons and
communications with the astrocytes being
dysregulated you see here the little
g-protein coupled receptor so there's a
signaling through these g-protein
coupled receptors and the astrocyte
there and the brain we actually see
these receptors not only on the neuron
and the synaptic cleft driving in the
endogenous cannabinoids signaling for
for neurological and pre synapse and
synapse this is driving all neurons so
when we think about these spasticity
diseases that that I talked about with
ALS and and multiple sclerosis lou
gehrig Anson's disease the
fasciculations the the the seizures in
the children with autism spectrum
disorders
it's these receptors that are being
dysregulated the psychoses even the
psychoses we see in young people who
have dysregulated cb1 receptors in fact
it's the it's the agonist of the cb2 the
TA
see that could actually stop the
psychoses rather than driving the
addiction as we think so here we have
the communication between the neurons
expressing crosstalking receptors and
the astrocytes and a calcium signaling
that that is discussed in the ion
channels and we show now the next point
that the cannabinoids are actually there
if we blow up in that in that neuron the
brain the heart and the muscles have the
most mitochondria so this is because
that's the energy powerhouses of of your
entire body with that without the
mitochondria with the respiratory chain
leading to 36 ATP verses - you can think
about all of these diseases myalgic
encephalomyelitis is is inflammation of
the brain and the muscles and it's long
been been known to be a mitochondrial
disease and and now we can start begin
to understand that the cannabinoids
signal through mitochondria right in the
right hand slide you see the
mitochondria actually has a
mitochondrial cb1 signaling so that you
can actually generate energy and and and
read restore energy at the level of
really restoring function and and these
are the mitochondrial diseases are
devastated where children actually die
before they're a few years old if they
have a primary deficiency in any one of
the chains of the mitochondrial
respiratory chain in any of these that
that leads to certain death because you
can't feel your brain your heart or your
muscles if you can't generate enough
energy so here the cannabinoids are even
a key to the respiratory transport chain
and there's that reference for that
paper in neuropsychopharmacology
she reviews just from a month or so ago
so perfect timing
for a discussion like this is we start
to really dig into seeing how we can
maintain homeostasis that's a balance in
our energy in in some of these
devastating diseases of an inability to
it's really an inability to fuel the
brain and the heart and the muscles at
the same time because of of defects and
pathogens on most viruses we'll take out
the mitochondria because they need the
energy as well so I show schematically
on the next slide all of the ways that
phyto cannabinoids so we've been talking
about just our endogenous cannabinoids
which we which we produce on our own
throughout our lifetime but as toxins
further and further dis regulate our our
immune system in our endocannabinoid
system because we haven't had plant
sources of cannabinoids whether it be
hemp which has been outlawed since the
1930s and isn't is from cannabis sativa
and the THC containing medical marijuana
it's called they're all cannabis sativa
or indica the main major strains because
that's been out of our diet out of our
world and the toxins that dis regulate
the machinery that I've just shown you
in the past few slides have been
increasing in our world and we really
have no response no therapeutic entity
to stimulate the phyto cannabinoids are
are ones that have been used
historically more than 14,000 years to
to really mitigate and prevent the
progression and development of these
diseases so they mitigate neuro trauma
ischemia is loss of oxygen so we talked
about those reactive oxygen species and
driving oxidative stress starving off
tissue so ischemia is the problem in
stroke major depressive disorders out
as disease it's everything we've talked
about in the last few slides are
interacting from that neuron where the
immune cells the microglia the
oligodendrocytes me astrocyte are
communicating via the cytokines
chemokines growth factors
neurotransmitters like nrf2
and and neuro hormones like for instance
vitamin d critical so these all of these
things go to disrupt the balance we call
it the homeostasis and at the level of
the brain and and this is what's driving
so if we can take phyto cannabinoids
from plants we can dampen that tissue
injury we can prevent the progression of
diseases and in facts as we saw a few
slides ago we could we could target
neurogenesis once we've once we've
stopped the injury and actually
regenerate healthy neurons and
neurological function and and you know
literally cure these diseases and for in
our scientific opinion as as slide as
the next slide shows it's really the
tissue macrophage that is driving all of
these processes we've talked about
microglia and and that's the brain
macrophage well the keratinocyte is the
skin macrophage so we think of all of
the we think of all the skin diseases
and that we see the very devastating
skin diseases that that could in fact be
be regulated by a cannabinoids via the
the cb2 receptor that we show THC the
psychoactive THC actually acts to drive
the various macrophages so each
different organ system from the lung
alveolar macrophages oh we can use
cannabinoids for lung cancer as part of
immune therapy in in our world we've
developed we developed drugs at the
national cane
sir Institute and through various
pharmaceutical companies like epidemics
for the last 30 or 40 years getting old
here but but you can you can target in
COPD the alveolar macrophages and
microorganisms that are that are driving
more and more COPD which is chronic
obstructive pulmonary diseases we look
at the liver Kupfer cell so this is the
cell that's critical to hepatitis C
hepatitis b HB RB and primary biliary
cirrhosis to cirrhosis of the liver we
think of fatty liver disease I I think
of all of the stories I've been reading
in in the journals lately it's the huge
incidence in fatty liver diseases in
people under 50 whether it be men or
women and I showed you that adipocyte
slide in that and the fat progenitor so
if you're driving the cb1 because of
toxins because you don't have enough CB
to driving the monocyte macrophage then
you can see how all of the diseases and
then some that I put on that on that
first introductory slide could be
mitigated at some level by the right
combination of phyto cannabinoids now
from plants because of course our
endogenous ones simply aren't enough to
overcome what is already a disease
process because we've been without them
since the last time most people
experience the endogenous cannabinoids
is during breastfeeding because that's
when mom is elaborating and producing
many of them through the milk and babies
getting that calming pain free learn to
suckle and mom and baby are both happy
it's that whole idea of joy inand amide
one of the key endogenous cannabinoids
Ananda mine is Sanskrit meaning joy
so the cannabinoid system could be seen
as joy pain free happy stress free
living and you can see at every level
the macrophage that
cb2 endogenous cannabinoids to the
development of the Hamada Pettit poetic
stem cell is could be modulated you know
in a way by cannabinoids in a positive
way rather than a damaging way with the
ballin resorption here at the bottom of
screen some chronic gum the IBD the
inflammatory bowel disease and Crohn's
disease at the level of the intestinal
macrophages so so many of these diseases
by simply modulating the macrophages at
the level of the myeloid stem cell could
actually be curative by looking and in
these ways I highlight the crosstalk in
in the next slide to show you the
pairing so crosstalk of receptor so
opioid receptors are also little g
protein-linked receptors there's these
channels I show you CB one and that
crosstalk doesn't only have to happen
between cb1 and cb2 it can happen
through these two these opioid receptors
so anxiety and depression and chronic
diseases anxiety is a type of pain it's
it's called it a nociception so it's a
different idea when we think of anxiety
so simply using to be one rich and
targeting aggregate agonists and
preparations of cannabinoids can
actually lead to tolerance and blame
blocking pain blocking effects of
opiates so it could actually reduce our
opioid addiction through cannabis you
know and missus this is where
understanding of biology and
biochemistry helps us to break down
these cultural walls that says oh no
joke cannabis is addictive and we can't
have THC well as long as you prevent THC
from signaling seed b1 you won't get the
psychoactive effects and we can do that
because we can just better build a
stronger magnet than THC to block those
effects with that that happens naturally
through blockers of various immune
molecules like in
amatory cytokine il-10 too many diseases
of pain has an il-1 receptor antagonist
so it actually is expressed in high
levels il-1 are a two-block il-1 one sia
ones job is done so that you don't
overdo it and cause these addictions so
on to depression and anxiety we think of
serotonin receptors so here again this
is where a therapeutic opportunity
exists with these memory impairments and
these these diseases of serotonin
receptors which of course serotonin and
dopamine receptors are key to
Parkinson's disease and a number of
other you know literally untreatable
diseases at least thought of and until
very recently Huntington's disease is
these adenosine receptors which are
highly immune suppressive and and this
is again it's usually a familial disease
by a problem with the a 2a receptors the
adenosine receptors where if you can
come in here and have some crosstalk in
agonist of cb1 and upregulate you can
ameliorate you can lessen the damage of
that genetic disease and stop the
expression so in in epigenetic world's
it's it's the expression of the diseases
not not the genetic component which
which are these familial diseases so
hunting is Huntington's disease runs in
families but you don't have to die and
you don't have to progress if you think
of curative therapies via modulating cb1
you know finally at the bottom of the
screen we have the chemokine receptors
so the chemokine receptors are the
trafficking molecules they're what takes
those blood monocytes to the brain so AB
you can down module they're what takes
cancer cells and leads to tumor
metastasis if a prostate cancer or any
other cancer doesn't metastasize to the
bone doesn't spread to the bone via the
trafficking Moll
you'll that takes them along by the hand
and takes them to the place where they
can live and thrive then you don't die
of cancer if you stop the metastases and
we have any number of drugs we've made
over the last few years like
angiogenesis inhibitors to stop cancer
spread because then you can you can live
with it and not die of it so the next
slide highlights that that very cross
talk idea when we talk about the pure
energic receptors so purines are
molecules like caffeine is appearing
adenosine guanine we have purines and
pyrimidines that make up the base pairs
of our DNA so in this open pain Journal
from 2010 it again earlier than been me
the papers I've been discussing today
it showed where there were actually
there was actually crosstalk between
that adenosine receptor on that monocyte
macrophage and that activate and m1 is
it's the bat macrophage no matter if
you're in cancer or anything else
they're they're they're bad
pro-inflammatory when they get to m2
that's driving the cancer or driving the
neurological disease and as shown here
it's affecting what we call it damage at
a distance the neuron so that's by ATP
which is appearing and and so when these
when ATP and those energy molecules get
outside the cells because the cells are
dying they become danger signals so they
tell the the immune system to shut down
and become immune suppressive and so
it's this crosstalk and and and the
suppression of these inflammatory
cytokines then that that is a problem
because an immune suppressed person will
develop cancer or progress in cancer
because you need the right immunity and
that's where you need that stem cell at
the very beginning with tgf-beta driving
that HoMedics stem cell away from the
myeloid lineage that is toxic the
activated and inflamed
towards the resting microglia which is
doing its job of surveilling and
removing toxins so the next slide shows
you just the list of all of the effects
so the plant derived Fido cannabinoids
are known as THC as we've discussed at
length CBD which cannabidiol they're
really the main constituents of whether
it be hemp or cannabis there's very
little THC opportunity in most but from
sativa and indica these have been
traditionally known to benefit patients
with these various diseases and the
cannabic arrow which metabolizes into
more THC also again now we understand
that's because of its regulation of the
amount of weightt extense l having the
anti-inflammatory and an inflammatory
agent so we can use these depending on
the concentrations of the drugs to to
actually help antipsychotics work better
essentially every drug we use in in
cancer or immune diseases right now we
can just supplement and we can take
advantage of synergies supplementing
with plant-derived phyto cannabinoids um
the phyto cannabinoids here shown here
and and lessen the actual drug that the
therapy that we're using in lessen the
off target or side effects so there are
so can cannabinoids phyto cannabinoids
are part of a class of compounds known
as terpenes so on this next slide i show
you all of the immunomodulatory and
anti-inflammatory terpenes so this
starts to give us some insights as to
the plants so one of the things that
indica or hemp have the most of is the
other terpene known as mercy and so this
is why the indica is thought to be
relaxing because the myrrh seen as an
essential oil these could be thought of
as essential oils
or oils and though there they help and
do sleep and relaxation
well the indica strains are very much
higher in these additional terpenes and
and and they obviously have the smells
that you taste with various cannabis
Tang sugars and oils other terpenes like
lemon even a little carbo filing the
peppery spicy is a compound known it
interacts with the receptor known as
trpv1 trpv1 is a key pain receptor and
the only known natural ligand is the
only unknown natural product that binds
that is trpv1 is Hot Chili Peppers so a
lot of the preparation we make with
cannabinoids with they're from from
cannabis the activity of the cannabis
could be modulated more by the terpene
and not at all by the cannabinoids the
CBDs the CBN's or the CB G's and even
THC so we could think of thinking about
the anti-inflammatory terpenes and since
cannabis is terpenes and thinking about
how we can formulate and reduce as much
as possible the psychoactive effects and
yet get a healing therapeutic benefit
really at almost no cost so I've talked
a lot about the cannabinoids and here's
two recent reviews and I think your
audience can see maybe 2015 and 2010 or
11 where there's there's um these are
very long lengthy reviews that give you
all kinds of agonist that we've used in
the lab nearly hundreds of references to
show you what I just talked about
briefly here today how these
cannabinoids and how targeting and
building the specificity out of the
ubiquity getting specificity out of
everywhere and making it yes they're
everywhere but can we can we be curative
using a shall I be irrational or
thoughtful process and using
cannabinoids
so we can do it both for cancer and we
can do it both for Parkinson's disease
and really alleviate the motor neuron
symptoms and regenerate new neurons and
replacing those damaged neurons so very
much in the literature not at all
hypothesis at this point in time and you
will see hundreds of references there
that's why I included it so finally we
can just summarize to say that the
endocannabinoid system is the immune
regulation and neuroprotection really
all a balance of the brain in the immune
system could be thought to be mediated
through receptor crosstalk not only with
pure energy receptors I just gave that
example because it's key in our
therapies today but also through the
regulation and and blocking the toxic
effects of aluminum glyphosate and many
of the causative agents for cancer draw
and auto-immune and neuro immune
diseases their lipid mediators they
exert you know pleiotropic effects and
complex effects on on the immune system
and the brain the endocannabinoids are
really the master regulators of the
innate and the adaptive immune access
what that's that axis between Astrid Lea
and T you know T cells and the monocyte
mangobaby so we can use these we can we
can affect we can effectively think
about them on the orchestrators of the
immune response and and make these a key
therapeutic target and just like we
could turn hiv/aids into a disease you
could live with we can turn we can use
these combination therapies to to cure
these 21st century acquired immune
deficiencies and with that I'll thank
you and take questions
thank you dr. mark Ribbit's with that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question drop down box
located on the far left
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the sign button will answer as
many questions as you have time for so
let's get started and see what kind of
questions are coming in from our
audience
dr. mega bits which stem cells are
primarily regulated by cb1 receptors CB
one primarily regulates the mesenchymal
stem cell that's the stem cell from
which the neurons in originate thank you
for that our next question is which stem
cells are primarily expressed on immune
cells um so the the endocannabinoid
receptor which is primarily expressed on
immune cells is known as C B 2 C 2 B 1
is primarily expressed on mesenchymal
stem cells and on in neurons and C B 2
is primarily expressed on immune cells
thank you for that and thank you to our
audience members for their great
questions know what I remind them any
questions I answer today will be
answered via email we have one more
question coming in true or false
THC regulates hematopoietic stem cells
that's absolutely true
that's that blood stem cell it's known
as HSC that's regulated by and it does
that through tgf-beta so tgf-beta is the
master regulator of the hematopoietic
stem cell and that's absolutely true
that THC D regulates at your thoughts
doctor Victor I want to thank you again
for your presentation and again for your
important research I'd also like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 29th 2018
you'll receive an email from laborat
letting you know that this webcast will
be
available for replay we share this
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
buh bye